good sunday morning to you everyone
yesterday's high up in the high
90s today will be slightly cooler our
normal is 90 for this time of the year
so
we are way above average and have been
that way lately
those temperatures are going to drop
finally near normal though we think
by tomorrow let me show you those
numbers in just a bit here's our doppler
network right now not picking up any
precip we could certainly use it here
they could really use it in california
they had all that rainfall in the
pacific northwest but we got
zip and looks like it's going to remain
that way even with that system that's
going to be pushing to the north there's
our water vapor satellite that storm
pushing up towards the east that brought
all that
rainfall the pacific northwest we're
going to have a cold front that's going
to slide down and as it does we'll see
those winds from the north for the day
today
and then behind that cold front we're
going to get gusty winds for
tomorrow and also on tuesday here's your
wind profile today
of course light breezes those gusts
between 30 to 35 for tomorrow could we
see a wind advisory
probably not one issued but we will see
breezy winds for tomorrow
and then tuesday look at that we'll have
some leftover breezes and we'll see some
more breezy winds again later on the
week after we warm up slightly
by midweek you'll see how much we're
warming up here in just a bit look at
that 90 degrees at 92
tomorrow and also on tuesday this is
right near average okay here's our
average line between 88 to 87 degrees 89
to 87 degrees i should say
so we'll be slightly above average warm
again by midweek we'll be warming things
up and then above average for sure
friday before we see another slight cool
down
for the weekend and that's why we get
breezes also later on the week as well
so autopsy turvy forecast but i think
we're done
with those 108 degree temperatures those
are over and done with
96 degrees for the day today hazy and
still warm
we'll see those north breezes between
5-15 some of you could get up to 20 for
the day today but like we said
the strongest winds will be tomorrow
forecasted highs for our sunday 95 in
north las vegas along with spring valley
let's see let's head over to summit 93
got a lot of views in centennial hills
94 for you up there in providence
95 from mountains edge a lot of viewers
there too in the southwest along with
southern highlands 98 sunrise mountain
nellis 97
north las vegas we love you guys 95
degrees for your high
for our sunday 93 94 for boulder city in
laflin you'll come in at triple digits
death valley for sure triple digits
at 108 degrees so here's your forecast
looking ahead
wind on monday temperatures drop like we
talked about we showed you these numbers
earlier but look at the overnight lows
beautiful
temperatures in the mid high 60s and
then low 70s by later on the week
that's your most accurate forecast have
an awesome sunday